veamos más cosas para reflexionar sobre
esta cuestión de mano de obra contra
capital hemos mencionado muchas veces
que para producir cualquier cosa
necesitamos ambos mano de obra y capital
la cuestión es que conforme producimos
dicha salida o producto como decidimos
cuánto va para la mano de obra y cuánto
va para el capital una forma de pensar
en ello es ver cuál de ellos tiene un
mayor apalancamiento si regresamos a la
era dorada o el pico de la revolución
industrial las personas con el mayor
apalancamiento eran los dueños del
capital pues las industrias del
crecimiento eran los trenes plantas
manufactureras y personas que buscaban
encontraban petróleo así que el capital
tenía todo el apalancamiento la mayoría
de la mano de obra empleada era poco
especializada y eran vistos por los
dueños del capital como un producto así
que la mayor parte de la salida del
ingreso al capital el autor del libro da
a entender que podemos estar entrando a
una segunda era dorada debido a que el
rendimiento del capital está siendo más
grande que el crecimiento y cada vez más
de la riqueza va para este
pero hagamos un experimento mental para
reflexionar y que cada quien llegue a
sus propias conclusiones pensemos en el
mundo en el que vivimos y usaremos a
silicon valley como ejemplo ya que
muchos pueden argumentar que es uno de
los mejores indicadores de cómo no sirve
a la economía y la industria del siglo
21 comparemos la era dorada con silicon
valley hogar de empresas como google
facebook y apple las cosas en silicon
valley tratan sobre capital o sobre mano
de obra las industrias en silicon valley
se dedican a la creación de tecnología y
a la creación de software el software en
particular requiere muy poco capital no
requiere de plantas de manufactura
millonarias no necesita demasiado
terreno al contrario se puede escribir
software en el dormitorio o en el closet
así es como yo comencé
así pues silicon valley trata más acerca
de la mano de obra aunque no del tipo de
mano de obra que se tenía en la edad
dorada donde se tenían personas
trabajando en líneas de ensamblaje o en
fábricas haciendo el mismo
una y otra vez en silicon valley tienen
mano de obra con mayores habilidades y
especialización así que hay mano de obra
altamente especializada altamente
especializada
y es una realidad que aquí la mano de
obra altamente especializada se ve como
un diferenciador mucho más fuerte para
una organización o individuo que el
capital
de hecho la dinámica que se ve cada vez
más en sillicon valley es que hay mucho
capital el cual se ve como un producto
persiguiendo a un equipo de 12 5
personas que crearon algo durante los
últimos meses y que se está valorando en
10 millones de dólares o 50 millones de
dólares vemos organizaciones como
facebook o what's up con valoraciones de
miles de millones de dólares basado
solamente en la salida de mano de obra
especializada se necesita algo de
capital para las máquinas los servidores
y las oficinas pero nada comparado con
la edad dorada el espacio de oficinas se
considera como un producto los
servidores también pero la mano de obra
altamente especializada no se considera
como un producto la pregunta que debemos
hacerlos es
este el caso y decide si r se mantendrá
mayor que se y más del ingreso ir al
capital o quizá vaya cada vez más a la
mano de obra especializada algo que
quizá ustedes se hayan dado cuenta es
que silicon valley no trata solamente
con software sino también con hardware
por ejemplo apple computers escribe el
software pero también son conocidos por
sus productos de hardware por ejemplo el
iphone el ipad y sus computadores que
hay de dicha industria que requiere de
mucho capital pensemos en cómo se
desarrolla su iphone o ipad son
diseñadas diseñadas por apple en
cupertino california y así lo indican en
sus cajas y envían su diseño a muchas
otras empresas estos son sólo algunos de
los proveedores de apple y estas son
industrias de capital intensivo pero
desde el punto de vista de apple muchas
de éstas aunque no todas son
desarrolladores de productos de manera
que si éstas no dan el precio deseado
por componente el cliente se irá a
buscar
la empresa que produzca el mismo
componente y estas empresas juntan los
componentes y los envían de vuelta a
paul en donde se empacan y comercializan
cuál es el aspecto de mayor valor en
esta cadena de producción pues
claramente el diseño y la mercadotecnia
si no me creen deberían revisar el
tamaño de la proporción del ingreso
generado por un iphone que va para apple
y el tamaño de la proporción que va para
los proveedores una forma de pensar en
ello es que esto se parece más a la mano
de obra manufacturera a gran escala de
la era de oro aunque aún aquí la
investigación y desarrollo tienen un
papel muy importante lo cual no ocurría
en la era dorada y la investigación y
desarrollo es mano de obra altamente
especializada aunque se requiere de
capital pero cuando vemos el valor real
creado está en esta parte del diseño y
la mercadotecnia o comercialización el
aspecto creativo de esto y aunque
ustedes tienen que llegar a sus propias
conclusiones esto por sí solo no
garantiza que no tengamos otra era
dorada
porque aunque esto indica que no tanto
del ingreso irá al capital si irá a la
mano de obra altamente especializada la
cual es un pequeño subconjunto de tu
boda la mano de obra lo cual causa
desigualdad aunque de forma diferente de
lo ocurrido en la era de oro en donde
iba a parar a los dueños del capital
aquí irá a parar a las manos de los
trabajadores altamente especializados es
aquí donde entran en juego las fuerzas
de convergencia y piketty parece algo
escéptico en su habilidad para compensar
a las fuerzas de la acumulación de
capital pero si podemos tener más
personas que participen como mano de
obra altamente especializada podríamos
tener una fuerza de convergencia para
equilibrar las cosas y evitar que
entremos a otra era dorada